les appels à la mobilisation semble
enfin se multiplier en faveur des
rwandais réfugiés au zaïre dispositions
prises par le gouvernement français par
les américains et appels lancés par le
hcr le haut commissariat de l'onu pour
les réfugiés
il y a urgence très grande urgence
florence mavic des silhouettes
fantomatiques noyé dans les brumes
recroquevillé au bord des chemins ou
errant à la recherche de nourriture
ces millions de réfugiés ont passé les
portes de l'enfer
et si la mort les a épargnés pendant les
massacres
elle les retrouve ici dysenterie famine
épuisement choléra selon msf l'épidémie
naissante a déjà tué 800 personnes dans
la seule journée d'hier les médecins ont
le plus grand mal à se frayer un chemin
parmi les cadavres
aucune organisation humanitaire n'a la
capacité logistique de les évacuer ou de
les enterrer décemment et parmi les
équipes de secours
on n'arrive toujours pas à croire que
pareil drame ait pu arriver si vite
c'est incroyable c'est vraiment dur mais
on continue une goutte d'humanitaires
dans cet océan de détresse l'aide
alimentaire est encore réduite à la
portion congrue
faute d'avion et de camions en nombre
suffisant l'aéroport de goma et les
routes sont saturés outre la nourriture
c'est désormais l'approvisionnement en
eau qui inquiète le plus les équipes de
secours
l'eau source de vie mais aussi
redoutables alliés du choléra
lorsqu'elle est insalubre il faudrait
distribuer 5 millions de litres par jour
la ration de survie quotidienne est
estimée à 5 litres par personne
à peine 180 mille litres sont répartis
au milieu de cette immense foule de
l'eau il y en a pourtant dans le lac
kivu proche de goma les réfugiés s'y
rendent
mais saft il que si cette eau n'est pas
traitée elle devient un poison mortel
médecins sans frontières souhaite
aménager rapidement des centres
nutritionnels intensifs plusieurs repas
quotidiens seraient distribués mais
impossible de nourrir et donc de sauver
tout le monde le cauchemar ne prendra
fin que si les rangs des regagnent leur
pays
les nouveaux dirigeants leur promettent
qu'ils vivront en sécurité il semblerait
que des groupes est repassé la frontière
préféra encore un avenir très incertain
aux ravages du choléra